[Musique]
retrouvez allons-nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la Réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission
allons l'émission Ça a découvert réunion
sans parler alors allons-nous
[Musique]
dans la commune de Sainte-Rose pas trop
loin du gîte du bolcos regarde bien j'ai
dit volcan 2230 mètres d'altitude nous
ça nous a fait nous sommes prêtes une
partie du sentier découverte et nous va
être à nous au pas de bellecom là-haut
alors le sentier découverte coucou les
appels comme ça alors ici si nous
regardent bien noter ça des modules nana
11 comme ça je vais pas à court et ce
bout de module là les spicano comment la
végétation la reprise vie sera la
volcanique ok en tout cas
comment allez-vous mais ça va bien
bonjour dites-moi vous allez où comme ça
là et ben nous on fait le sentier
découverte on va aller au pad Bellecombe
en fait on voulait aller au café de la
Rivière de l'Est mais on a pris la pluie
du coup on va faire quelque chose de
plus simple est-ce que vous avez regardé
la météo avant de venir
sur le volcan donc c'était l'occasion du
coup est-ce que vous avez déjà venu sur
le gîte du volcan le gîte même moi je
suis venu il y a longtemps c'était en
c'était un gîte assez rustique très
pratique parce que c'est vraiment juste
à côté du volcan donc quand on est en
vacances c'est pratique de pouvoir être
juste à côté du départ et ben merci en
tout cas
je vais monter aussi allez salut ciao
ciao bonne journée
pour le sentier faut bien repérer ses
traces rouge là que nous va découvrir
tout le long du sentier et c'est les
Gaïa aussi en début de chez nous la
nouvelle trouve le bon verre le bon le
blanc de votre aussi le lamba ville et
chinois à toi non encore ici c'est le
petit tamarin des hauts
alors ici nous les biens sentiers
découverte 2265 m le sentier découverte
lisez pas là d'accord et nous ça nous va
faire nous on va aller par là
bonjour bonjour comment il est là
bonjour monsieur
juge aussi 10 minutes à peu près
l'enclos et les olé en vacances
je suis à la Normandie Normandie votre
meilleur souvenir c'est quoi là depuis
que vous êtes là là ah c'est la
randonnée la plongée avec les poissons
c'est s'émerveilleux c'est quoi dire de
il y a rien de plus beau merci bien et
bonne fin de vacances
[Musique]
et ben voilà au bout de ma montre 45
minutes mais arrive au pas de belles
comme alors pas de belles comme je
regarde bien 2319 mètres d'altitude et
ben nous nous on va juste aller voir le
Piton de la fois
une petite pause comment allez-vous ça
va bien ça va très bien dites-moi vous
revenez où comme ça là on revient du
Piton de la Fournaise c'est vrai vous
avez été jusqu'à là jusqu'à là alors
est-ce que vous avez vu quelque chose
oui on a vu un grand trou c'est ça c'est
un grand trou et c'est noir en bas
j'habite à la Réunion non moi je viens
du Canada
Canada la Réunion c'est quoi la
différence quelle température je crois
et pourquoi vous êtes décidé de venir
faire cette randola aujourd'hui si sur
les de la Fournaise j'en avais
entendu que des beaux mots et je peux
dire la même chose c'est magnifique ça
vaut le déplacement ça vaut le
déplacement et qui c'est qui vous a
parlé de la Réunion c'est un rêve pour
moi de devenir ici ça faisait a pas très
longtemps que je voulais j'adore les
randos et tout enfin haute-savo on est
servi mais mais là les paysages sont
quand même différents donc non frère je
pense c'est incroyable bon en tout cas
bonne continuation merci
du paysage qui est juste au dessus
bonjour bonjour
alors ici nous voilà
notre gars en tout cas il est vraiment
Gaillard et le temps ben nous va
brouillard comment ça revenir alors et
nous ça nous ça a fait nous a fait
demi-tour et nous va aller à la
découverte du gîte du volcan
au niveau du gîte et bien ouais madame
avec un casque blanc
bonjour
Alors là vous voyez la le chantier de
reconstruction du gîte donc c'est le
seul hébergement sur le massif du volcan
il faut savoir que
on reçoit entre 300 et 500 000 visiteurs
par an et le gîte en lui-même
accueille jusqu'à 12000 unités par an
donc les départements propriétaires des
lieux assez engagé sur la rénovation de
ces bâtiments et pour rendre plus
confortable l'accueil du des touristes
locaux nationaux et internationaux et
consomment
on livre le bâtiment on déconstruit la
partie basse ou
est actuellement le gîte provisoire et
ensuite on pourra pleinement exploiter
ce site
en tout cas tu as trouvé la même
là on pointe un petit parti du sentier
découverte et nous la vue que bientôt
nous un nouveau gîte nous va gagner des
kovalie ok la Réunion allons prendre le
temps Vitali et pour ça on nous a un
prochain épisode de l'émission à nous
cette fois nous sera ma fat rochefat
dans la semaine
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présenté par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]